bladesmiths this is the strength and
durability test I will test your knife
by delivering four chops to get through
these three coconuts I want to make sure
that the knife doesn't come apart and
the edge will retain its sharpness
Justin you're up first
[Music]
Justin you almost did no shaping on this
handle so it makes the knife a lot more
difficult to hang on to I nearly missed
the coconut because of it however I
don't feel any chips or Nicks still feel
Sharp
you did a good job thank you Kelly you
ready I'm ready
Kelly your handle the cross section is a
little thicker in the back tapering
towards the front which makes for a
really good grip overall it cut well I
mean I blazed through those coconuts
pretty easy well
I can see the Tang right here through
this epoxy and there's only about two
inches of this in the handle so I was
throwing off my accuracy because there's
nothing to counterbalance the blade now
fortunately it is still together it
didn't come off there's no damage to
your Edge we cut through the Coconuts
they made it
next up is the sharpness test we're
going to turn it over to Doug for that
to see if your Blade's Edge is sharp I
will slice across these rubber water
bladders Justin you're up I have no idea
what to expect
I've gotten through the coconut
chocolate I have no idea how this will
perform
your blade has good balance it feels
good but in this sharpness test it's not
about chopping or using velocity it's
about slicing to test the edge and in
this particular case it did not cut
Kelly you're up next you ready sure I
think it's sharp enough to cut through
but I'm not positive because I have
never cut through a water bladder
well I like the balance of your blade I
like the way it feels in the hand but
when it came to the idea of slicing it
did lacerate it just didn't slice all
the way through
will you're up are you ready yes sir
[Music]
well your blade is light
but the handle
a little small it likes to move around
in my hand but when I slice across the
bladder you can see a line right here so
it did lacerate but it did not cut
through
I think it'll be a pretty tough decision
for the judges and I feel like I'm
pretty much equal with my other blade
Smith and I feel like I have a pretty
good chance of being able to go through
blade Smiths the judges have made their
final decision
time for one of you to leave the forge
will
your blade did not make the cut
will I really liked where you were going
with your blade when you started out but
you made a handle that was basically
held together with nothing but glue and
I know that you noticed where you would
ground through into that Center epoxy
he didn't do anything to address those
problems that's why we've got to let you
go
I understand
well please surrender your weapon
I agree with their decision 100 percent
you know being young ain't exactly an
excuse to not do as well but I
definitely learned a lot not just from
the others but a lot about myself I love
my craft and I'll continue to do it I'm
going back to my hometown with my head
held high because I'll be the most
famous person there